bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro du cetud culture et tout
de suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 18
octobre
c'est l'histoire de six passionnés fans
de supertramp avec leurs concerts et
rendent hommage au groupe mythique
britannique cover 30 sera sur la scène
du théâtre espace coach de plaisir ce
week-end on ne le présente plus omar sy
est à l'affiché d'un nouveau film le
knock est l'histoire d'un médecin fils
où il présentait le long métrage la
semaine dernière à saint quentin en
yvelines et bertreau pigné du cinéma les
yeux d'elsa à saint-cyr-l'ecole donnera
deux rendez vous en rendez vous pour
voyager un autre pour frissonner comment
observer une oeuvre d'art à guyancourt
une exposition interrogent le visiteur
d'une image à l'autre illusion
artistique présente une dizaine
d'artistes nationaux et internationaux
leurs oeuvres joue avec votre perception
celle de vos yeux et de votre cerveau
l'exposition est à découvrir jusqu'au 10
décembre à la salle d'exposition de
guyancourt c'est de regarder l'oeuvre
est en effet cette oeuvre a besoin
d'être vu peut-être avec attention
en effet on a autant de sculptures de
peintures d'objets qui permettre
justement de prendre de la distance par
rapport à ce que c'est que l'art et je
pense que c'est important que les
enfants prennent ce temps de regarder de
pouvoir observer une deuxième exposition
met à versailles cette fois l'ex passe à
l'espace richaud accueille pour la
première fois un artiste contemporain
joseph dadoun actuellement résident sur
versailles grand parc
il travaille le goudron le fer et le
cuivre nicolas landry pour les images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une vie paradoxal joseph dadoun explore
la dualité le jour la nuit les couleurs
le noir un noir profond celui du goudron
travailler avec des outils d'ouvriers
le noir c'est c'est un point de vue de
la nuit la nuit on a su le cosmos
on a notre terre qui se retrouvent dans
le noir avec la lumière de la lune
et si vous remarquez bien dans ce noir
vous vous voyez la lumière s'accroche
aux éléments donc c'est un élément
poétique et c'est aussi un sentiment
c'est ce sentiment de simplicité de
grande humilité
un noir qui renvoie à la terre un
goudron reflet de son passé celui d'une
ville ouvrière à la frontière avec gaza
une ville en conflit bombardé une terre
noire où poussent la vie
de là je ne pouvais que qu'avancer dans
un espoir et me projeter dans un espoir
et dans cet espoir il ya ces fleurs et
je continue à être naïf et penser qu'à
travers mon art peut-être les cultures
pourront se rapprocher et que les des
deux côtés les gens feront la paix une
vision utopique assumée par l'artiste
avec sion joseph dadoun veut sillonné la
vie et le collectif les beatles queen
les rolling stones ou encore supertramp
le groupe britannique fondé dans les
années 60 et 70 sont aujourd'hui devenus
meetic
beaucoup de fans leur rendent hommage en
montant des tribus de bande et le l'un
de ces passionnés avec nos plateaux
philippe taillefer fondateur et membre
de cover tron tout ça bonsoir
alors quand bertrand que joua plaisir ce
vendredi le groupe a été fondé en 2013
est déjà adoubé par roger rogers aus
auxonne parure lui-même l'un des
fondateur de supertramp
oui oui on a eu la chance de le
rencontrer en 2014 et il nous a dit
qu'il aimait beaucoup
on a été quelqu'un quelque part un petit
peu adoubé certaine surprise voire où
l'avion devait se croiser en loge
c'était une surprise de pouvoir passer
autant de temps avec lui alors j'ai
désordre et les titres vous êtes c'est
sur scène six musiciens avec une passion
commune une passion voire un peu plus
d'après ce que j'ai compris oui oui plus
que de la phase i fo reviennent
l'obsession et 1 to cash chez chez moi
il ya de l'obsession et bah c'est une
musique un peu spécial un peu compliqué
à la l'air simple elle n'est pas du tout
il ya beaucoup de petits détails
les groupes des années 70 il était
capable de passer huit mois en studio à
faire des essais avec des bruitages et
tout ça donc il a fallu recréer tout ce
qu'ils sont une obsession d'enfance
venue des parents peut-être plus tard en
est pouvant la musique noire une
obsession d'enfance ouailles en écoutant
les vinyles les textes et des vinyles et
dans une obsession danse ans clame alors
vous chercher à interpréter des versions
le plus proche possible des titres
originaux
si vous arrivez à y mettre un peu votre
patrie ce que vous avez tous les six une
carrière oui les musiciens vous êtes
chanteur oui on a tous une carrière
parallèle mais bon je pense qu'on y met
notre patte sans le faire exprès on se
l'approprient et on le restitue à notre
façon mais l'intérêt devait être ne
m'être vraiment tous les détails
importants pour que les gens en tandis
qu'ils ont aimé entendre ce qu'ils ont
aimé
en écoutant les disques de supertramp
alors pour se rendre compte de ce que ça
donne à l'ecg très de logica leçons mais
[Musique]
toujours
oui
mais bon
[Musique]
hamon
sam
[Musique]
c'est sans doute un des titres les plus
célèbres lors de vos concerts vous jouez
que ceux connus vous en amener d'autres
avaient un peu plus n'ont fait vraiment
de tours ce que supertramp y avait pas
que des tubes
il avait cette particularité d'avoir
fait la musique contemplative à la pink
floyd genesis et aussi des gros tubes
donc on fait de tout en fait détourné
déjà un peu partout en france et 11
aujourd'hui même à la cigale oui en fait
on est partie timidement sur une de
prestations en 2013 on a commencé petit
et puis ça double tous les ans il ya un
engouement vraiment se passe quelque
chose
le public vient voir quoi un groupe
finalement n'aurait jamais pu voir parce
qu'ils ne sont plus exact exactement
puis 83 ils sont plus ensemble donc vous
ne pouvez plus avoir le mélange des
répertoires super temps qu'on tourne
plus depuis 2010 il reste roger hodgson
donc les gens viennent écouter
supertramp c'est ça qui veulent du super
trop à vous le disais tout à l'heure
vous avez dû faire aussi de la recherche
parce qu'ils en faisaient eux déjà
beaucoup dans les années 70 vous avez
même travaillé pendant presque un an
avant de monter sur scène tous les six
la musique est exigeante
oui oui on s'y attendait parce que
l'équipe qui m'entoure ce sont tous des
musiciens chevronnés de grandes qualités
de grand talent on s'attendait pas à
affronter de telles difficultés
c'est une musique très précises elle
extrêmement sophistiqués donc il a fallu
passer du temps à créer non seulement
les sons mais aussi l'ambiance les
coeurs retrouvez les bons instruments et
surtout créer cette alchimie qui était
si particulière c'était un groupe avant
tout c'est pas juste des individualités
c'est un groupe et les voit aussi
peut-être beaucoup travaillé sur les
voies y avait un gros travail de voir tu
perds tu rends comme beaucoup de groupes
à l'époque et tous les 6 comment vous
vous êtes rencontrés par diverses
j'avais cru comprendre une tournée star
80 peut-être certains un peu de tout oui
alors moi je fais cet art 80 mais il y
en a qui font des communes et musicale
on a des carrières parallèles mais on se
connaissait on se connaît depuis à peu
près 17 ans donc ça fait longtemps c'est
une petite famille musicale
donc on en parlait comme ça pour rigoler
puis on a fini par le faire pour voir ce
que ça donne aussi un deuxième extrait
cette fois c'est goodbye stranger tiré
du sixième opus breakfast in america qui
a eu un très grand succès en français je
me trompe pas on les écoute
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le public dans la salle en entendant ça
il reste assis sur son fauteuil où ça
alors je sais très marrant il ya de tout
et de tous on s'attendait pas non plus à
ça il ya des gens qui bougent qu'ils ont
envie de bouger et des antilles ferme
les yeux il ya des gens qui pleurent
il ya des gens qui récite toutes les
paroles pendant deux heures donc on n'a
pas le droit à l'erreur
c'est vraiment un répertoire qui a
marqué les gens et notamment en france
breakfast in america last album là c'est
la troisième meilleure vente en variété
de tous les temps en france c'est à dire
devant sardou dans plein d'autres
artistes c'est incroyable et du côté on
va dire composition du public vous avez
des adultes des nostalgiques ou même des
enfants parce que on voit souvent dans
les tribunes devant des parents quand
même des enfants pour faire découvrir
leur jeunesse leur eh oui c'est ce qui
se passe au début on avait vraiment que
les les quinquagénaires où les quadras
voilà qui ont un petit peu sur les côtés
ça jeunes maintenant on a de tous les
parents amènent les enfants et c'est en
train de bouger aussi tout ça il ya une
recherche ensemble les jeunes
recherchent
merci philippe taillefer devenu en
plateau alors qu'est ce qu'on va faire
tremper sur la scène du théâtre espace
coluche de plaisir c'est le vendredi 20
octobre à 20h30 merci beaucoup
avant de refermer cette page musique une
autre date le rappeur mhd se produira à
la mairie ce de trappes ce samedi
extraits
[Musique]
présent la famille au complet le bonheur
de bossut
[Musique]
pakaya
à
on part maintenant à saint-cyr-l'ecole
bertrand pigné des yeux d'elsa à deux
rendez vous cinéma vous proposer on
écoute le coup de coeur cinéma aux yeux
dès les 1 cette semaine
ce n'est pas un mais deux coups de coeur
c'est des coups de coeur de vacances il
ya deux soirées qu'on organise donc
pendant ses vacances
la première a lieu le 28 octobre c'est à
l'occasion de la journée mondiale du
cinéma d'animation
c'est un peu traditionnelle au cinéma
les yeux d'elsa on met toujours un
l'accent sur le cinéma d'animation en
octobre et là on le mettra sur le cinéma
d'animation japonais en présentant loué
l' île aux sirènes à 21h et dans un
recoin de ce monde à 18h30
donc c'est une soirée qui finira tôt et
qui est destiné à tous les publics avec
deux films d'animation japonais et la
deuxième soirée qu'on organise c'est
donc le vendredi 3 novembre une soirée
stephen king à partir de 20h30 avec ça
le film que tout le monde dont tout le
monde a entendu parler la reprise du
téléfilm très connu du livre très connu
de stephen king
là dans une version à priori très très
strangers things pour ceux qui
connaissent cette série et puis on
poursuivra la soirée avec un film
formidable un des meilleurs film de
brian de palma et un une des meilleure
adaptation d'un film de stephen king
carrie au bal du diable qui ressort en
version restaurée et que nous aurons
donc en sortie en ressortit nationale à
l'occasion de cette soirée
j'espère vous retrouver nombreux donc le
28 octobre pour la soirée animations
et le 3 novembre pour la soirée stephen
king au cinéma les yeux d'elsa à très
bientôt
une avant-première maintenant celle du
dernier film avec omar sy knox c'est
l'histoire d'un ex filou devenu médecin
le film qui sort aujourd'hui a été
présentée par remercier la réalisatrice
lorraine levy la semaine dernière à
l'ugc skywest retour sur cette soirée
c'est une confidence qu'on ne pensait
pas entendre omar sy et nerveux quand il
présente un nouveau film à 50 en ligne
et pourtant
l'accueil est toujours chaleureux pour
le natif de trappes
passage aux devises et passage pur
bonheur de venir à skywest et le cinéma
où je venais quand je séchais les cours
il ya mon lycée qui est juste devant
donc c'est une forme de pèlerinage quoi
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui la dote par contre il est
beau très beau
vous n'avez pas dit a dit quoi et qu'il
était qu'il était quoi quand cette fois
il est neuf
un médecin filous qui arrive dans la
creuse dans les années 50 une libre
adaptation de la pièce du même nom écrit
par jules romains en 1923 un petit filou
qui arrive dans ce petit village de
saint maurice avec un petit projet un
peu magnifique même un peu un très très
banal il vient donc clairement pour ce
faire de l'oseille
mais heureusement il va être sauvée va
être sauvée dans ce film il ya ya ya
on parle aussi de la rédemption la
deuxième chance il des choses qui
peuvent se modifier dans le bon sens
bande l'epim précédent en fait j'adapte
et le texte à mes personnages
et là j'ai dû adapter mon personnage aux
textes j'ai fait le travail inverse
c'est la première fois que je faisais ça
et c'était très intéressant
l'intérêt pour moi c'était de prendre
cette pièce et de l'emmener ailleurs et
c'est une c'est vraiment une très libre
adaptation on retrouve tout ce qui fait
la saveur le sel de cette pièce les
répliques cultes qui font partie de
notre mémoire collective et de notre
patrimoine littéraire mais pour autant
adapté c'est trahir avec laval
des éditions gallimard et de l'ayant
droit de jules romains j'ai vraiment
imaginer un passé un présent et un
avenir
j'ai appris son passé criminel tu as un
menteur reste à nantes
il m'a fallu déjà ses mille et un petit
métier pour ne pas mourir de faim et
alors un film à la distribution
prestigieux sabine azéma rufus ou encore
christian hecq n'a que 120 salles ce
mercredi 18 octobre
la population de saint maurice est bien
portante
les gens bien portants sont des malades
qui s'ignorent monsieur le maire le nom
un mot de théâtre à présent avec le
festival la mort de rire à saint cyr
l'école
il revient du 20 au 22 octobre pour une
quatrième édition
écoutez au fémur et elle était l'invitée
de camille lambert dans le 7-8 loisirs
du 13 octobre le théâtre souvent les
gens l'imaginent avec le molière le
classique le théâtre classique et nous
on voulait un peu coupé les préjugés en
fait et c'est pour ça qu'on s'est axée
sur la comédie est vrai le but c'était
de faire rire le festival mort de rire
qu'a lieu au moment de la toussaint
voilà c'était un peu pour faire le jeu
de mots et puis réconciliés les
spectateurs avec le théâtre un petit
clin d'oeil aussi justement la fête de
la toussaint et on précise que ce sont
des troupes amateurs et vous l'avez dit
certains viennent même de loin aurillac
pour raconter
cossart comment avez vous choisi chaque
chaque spectacle chaque troupe
c'est un appel à candidatures en fait un
prêt on reçoit pas mal de demandes avec
des vidéos
parfois on est invité à les voir
directement les spectacles et puis
d'après faut faire son choix c'est pas
toujours facile
et voilà pas ceux qui sont pas là cette
année on espère les avoir l'année
prochaine pourquoi pas un petit bol
manquant même oui bah oui faut essayer
satisfaire tout le monde
le but 2-2 nous comédiens amateurs c'est
de pouvoir jouer un maximum est de se
faire connaître
l'intégralité de cet entretien est à
retrouver sur notre site internet de
l'humour aussi à guyancourt avec le one
woman show d'olive et amour une maman
cash caustique égoïste et décomplexé
avant goût on ne naît pas mais indigne
en ligue 1 n'ont jamais n'était pas
[Musique]
une enfant pardonne beaucoup appris
n'ont pas le choix s'ils veulent manger
j'aimerais malheureusement l'expérience
montre que les enfants
wells a quand même parfois un peu plus
con que prévu
on continue c'est cette culture avec nos
deux nouveaux invités s'user mal très et
bernard delattre vous êtes tous deux
auteurs et participer au premier salon
du livre d'elancourt qui se tient ce
week-end le 22 octobre plus précisément
bernard de l'ade vous fait aussi partie
de l'organisation parce que l'idée vient
de l'association les amis du passé
d'elancourt oui tout à fait donc je
faisais les vignes avait que six nations
qui existe depuis 30 ans qui a fait des
livres sur les vignes l'école des
langues ou qu'ils avaient envie de faire
une autre un événement j'aurais dit
pourquoi vous faites pas interdit parce
que j'avais grâce à suzy maltret qu'ils
fassent en duo en face à lons de l'iss
depuis 9 ans sur rende mieux qu'elle
dirige et tout donc je vais un peu aidé
avec cette expérience dont on a pu
monter ce salon d'elancourt qui sera une
grande première avec 70 auteurs grande
70 auteurs vous dites parce que des
journalistes à des dessinateurs de la
bande dessinée des auteurs jeunesse ça
ratisse assez large pour attirer un
public large
oui on espère avoir un public familial
ça serait comme une grande librairie un
peu alors info rayon jeunesse et que le
libraire 17 main michel fourel donc y
aura des auteurs de bandes dessinées
marc bourgne un auteur qui a fait des
bandes dessinées aussi sur 14 18 qui
sera un des thèmes de l'histoire
l'histoire de le centenaire de 1917 est
aussi un hommage à blaise cendrars qui
est enterrée ou trembler sur maul et
suzie maltret aussi auteur combattants a
fait un recueil de poèmes précisément
tout à l'heure et notamment parmi les
invités les 70 auteurs il y en a un en
particulier qui est le président
d'honneur cette année
salah stétié pourquoi l'avoir choisi lui
parce que c'est un monsieur formidable
quoi c'est vraiment il ya une plume
extraordinaire ça monsieur qu'est né à
beyrouth qui a été secrétaire d'état au
liban au début de la guerre civile
il a été ambassadeur
du liban à l'unesco à paris ou pays bas
et au maroc
il a rencontré de gaulle quand il était
collégien à beyrouth en fait il ya un
parc où il a rencontré plein de
l'artiste à paris
enfin il a un parcours exceptionnel et
il a publié en jeu c'est pas 70 vivre il
a traduit kalil gibran
il a eu le prix saint simon pour son
autobiographie
formidable capitaux de trembler sur
moule où est enterré blessant un que
j'adore mais c'était une communauté
littéraire dans les yvelines alors ce
dimanche il y aura l'esl et les auteurs
qui dédicaceront leurs ouvrages
il ya aussi des rencontres des dédicaces
que j'ai dit et des conférences la
première sera fait par vous saisit mal
très vous avez parlé des auteurs
victimes de la grande guerre 14 18 08
août a fait je parlerai donc de blaise
cendras tout proche de nous puisqu'il
est au tremblay comme vient de le lire
monsieur delattre
je parlerai de d'autres bien sûr vous
allez parler de leur implication dans
l'airé crise on apporte bien sûr des et
clic droit rapporté et le fait aussi
qu'il soit disparu et qui n'ont pas pu
continuer leur carrière littéraire
je fus et il ya bien longtemps de cela
une élève de maurice genevoix et je me
souviens qu'avec je disais toujours là
me morice nous en avions souvent parler
et puis les choses se sont passées ainsi
gérard larcher m'avait demandé en 2014
de faire un ou deux ou trois poèmes
autour de la grande guerre pour un 11
novembre pour le cimetière ancien et ces
deux là qu'a démarré ce livre là bas
sorti en voilà tout à fait fin 2016 donc
et tout récent quelque part et qui va
être suivi et malheureusement il ne sera
pas à elancourt puisqu'il sera pas tout
à fait paru qui va être suivi par un
roman les mains nues ou l'autre siècle
c'est-à-dire que vous partirez de la
guerre 14 vous irez vers la guerre
l'autre guerre
et jusqu'à celle de la guerre d'algérie
l'autre siècle alors vous écrivez sur
les conflits mais pas seulement votre
premier ouvrage vous l'écrivez à 22 ans
et vous on part souvent dans la beauce
oui ce que vous êtes originaire de
là-bas ça vous inspire je suis
originaire de la beauce amoureuse de mon
pays
voilà j'ai été beaucoup de choses sur la
bosse notamment la tare dionne puisque
pour présenter la tare d'hillion j'ai eu
la chance d'être sur antenne 2 voilà et
puis voilà c'est mon socle bernard
delattre on l'a vu se sont beaucoup d
auteurs qui ont un pied dans les
yvelines c'est important de faire
connaître aussi au public le patrimoine
littéraire qu'on a chez nous gestion on
a invité des auteurs comme andré le
calme qui est de trappes qui fait d une
sorte de route à vélo peu dans la
tradition de descendre à tout ça donc
ces auteurs là ils sont pas souvent
invités on a voulu se mélange avec des
auteurs locaux pas très connu les faire
connaître qui se trouveront à côté de
jean françois kahn jean claude bourret
salah stétié donc c'est ça qui est
intéressant un peu voilà c'est on a
voulu vraiment donner la chance à des
jeunes auteurs aussi à côté d'auteurs
confirmés vous rencontrer régulièrement
vous même oui bien sûr parce que je fais
beaucoup de là j'arrive delà du salon du
mandat 25e heure du livre au mans il n'y
a pas très longtemps j'étais à chanceaux
sur sur l'os voilà et veillait sur nous
concerne brice puisqu'il était disparue
depuis quinze jours
quand j'y étais voilà oui je vais dans
beaucoup d'endroits je donne aussi
beaucoup de conférences
voilà et c'est ma façon d'aimer la
littérature une littérature que vous
allez partager avec le public dimanche
bernard delattre là c'est la première
toute première édition avec 70 auteurs
c'est à dire qu'il y aura bien une
deuxième où ceux déjà prévus ont déjà
beaucoup de demandes et qu'on commence à
la préparer déjà merci à tous les deux
d'être venu sur ce plateau nous parlait
donc du premier salon du livre à la
commanderie des templiers d'elancourt
c'est de 10h à 18h le dimanche 22
octobre et on passe maintenant à notre
agenda
[Musique]
la librairie le pavé du canal et
l'association trait d'union propose une
conférence débat sur l'histoire de la
colonisation française en invité
l'historien benjamin stora ça débute à
17h30 à l'université versailles saint
quentin et la magie va envahir montigny
le bretonneux vendredi soir kamel
magicien sera sur la scène de la ferme
du manet l'artiste a été révélée sur le
plateau du grand journal de canal+ son
nouveau spectacle mêle grande illusion
mentalisme et en donne un avant goût
[Musique]
roddick
[Applaudissements]
le site une culture est maintenant
terminée je vous remercie de nous avoir
suivi ce magazine est à revoir sur notre
site internet et sur notre application
mobile à mercredi prochain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]